luke and tom here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today
we're going to make a survival shelter
out of duct tape
yeah wait
wait for me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the key to making duct tape cordage is
you want to keep twisting it
until it untwists itself
what do you think of that i think it's
awesome
it's private swap
you want at least one twist per inch and
this is 60
feet of cordage so that's approximately
720
inches so you want to twist this about
720 times
if i'm really hauling butt i can do
about 80 rotations per minute
so to do 620 rotations takes about 10
minutes
stuff is very stretchy
all right there's one down
hey becca
uh oh it just broke my line luckily i
got some duct tape to fix that
it doesn't have to be exact
all right i'm turning three rolls of
duct tape into one giant
thick cord and it's a lot more work
pull that as hard as you can
all right jumped up here
that goes
so
we have already used up 14 rolls of duct
tape approximately 630
yards of tape day two
well i've been taping over my head for
two hours and my shoulders are killing
or i got the roof done but it's saggy
because the weight of the tape
is pulling the walls inward which causes
it to bow in the middle
so to fix that i am going to try to come
up with some sort of support system
holy mackerel i just used up my 36
roll of duct tape i thought three dozen
was gonna be enough
so i'm gonna go run to the store and
pick this up in a little bit
12 more rolls of duct tape
[Applause]
well i just went through another case of
duct tape that makes 48 rolls so far
i need to go to the hardware store
you guys excited to camp in this thing
all right nate you want inside yeah
oh it supports my leg
i'm six foot four at about 250 pounds
i busted a hole in this but that's okay
we can fix it with duct tape
[Applause]
so
all right threw in some extra
reinforcing let's see if uh
what happens now
oh this is more than a little scary
i'm so tired
[Music]
you guys are
you know what let's roll with this yeah
you know this is better find out how
much weight
what do you think babe great actually
jacob that's
that what do you guys think of the tent
yeah yeah
yeah and the change grade well guys now
that we've got the tent done
we need to do a couple other things we
need to see whether we can build a fire
using duct tape whether we can catch our
food using duct tape
and whether we can build sleeping bags
using duct tape
so far we've used 56 rolls of duct tape
tomorrow's gonna be a busier day though
we've got the shelter up now it's time
to get some food using duct tape
there you go we got some extra fine duct
tape cordage
well we're going to try to snare some
small game using duct tape
and first we got to find the right spot
here we have a ravine you've got this
log
crossing the ravine anytime you have a
log going across a ravine
or a stream there's going to be a lot of
foot traffic across that log
small animals like rabbits and weasels
and squirrels are going to be coming
across that log rather than anywhere
else and if you know where they're going
to be
you can know where to set your snare
so what we've got here is we've got a
little snare so that anything that tries
to go across this log
has to put its head through this hole
and once
they go through and they get their head
stuck they start thrashing around
and they go fall off the log or jump off
the log
then then they're hung well i'm gonna
hunt around and set up some more snares
and go back to camp and we're gonna go
and check these
in just a little bit there we go uh the
trap worked just like a charm
now of course we have videotaped how
successful this trap is but
we can't show it to you because we'd be
demonetized by youtube so
yes the trap worked perfectly all right
we skinned and gutted
the rabbit that we totally caught in our
duct tape snare
time to build a fire and get cooking
there we go he's on there
nice and tight rock salt on him
little pepper a lot of pepper
when you're hunting and trapping in a
survival situation like this
you have to use every bit of the animal
to survive so i'm gonna use
this rabbit hide and a few others which
i totally caught
in my duct tape snare
let's see how
hands down this is the most comfortable
survival shelter i've ever built
the furline blanket is actually really
comfy and
nice hey you want to wrap up the the
blanket
what do you think tom is that comfy but
it smells sons
all right we could ski for coffee
ready to try some rabbit yes
there's a lot of pepperoni yeah it
tastes like a hot dog to me
yeah bite right out of the rabbit
pretend you're a wolf
hey jake you want to try it yeah here
you like the rabbit
well got food and shelter taken care of
but we've got a little bit of a
rainstorm coming tonight
and uh we're gonna put this thing to the
test
well i'm just sitting here with a belly
full of rabbit watching the sunset
and burning up about 60 duct tape
cardboard centers this will this will
keep me pretty warm
well it's been fun sitting by the fire
but it's late and it's time to go into
bed and it's just gonna be me tonight
it's not really too comfortable trying
to fit multiple people in this thing so
i'm just gonna sleep in it for tonight
and maybe the boys will get to play in
it a little bit more later but
anyway i'm gonna go hit the sack and i'm
gonna go hop in here
let's see that'll work i need a place to
put my
phone and stuff
there we go got a cell phone pocket
and a place to put my glasses
it's a little nippy out but uh i'm gonna
go ahead and turn off the lights and i
will see you guys in the morning
well it's about two in the morning that
rain i was expecting just started
i'm actually pretty cozy
[Applause]
oh we got ourselves a leak we got
ourselves more than a few leaks
my hammock is filling up with water tarp
on top is leaking
but the one on the bottom is not and so
i have got a
a growing puddle of water
ah so this is turning into a bathtub
you have to know
[Music]
you know the worst part about waking up
in a pool of water
oh i've got to pee so badly
that was interesting
oh well it looks like there's a lot of
droplets here around the edges where
water's coming
around the tarp and then there's
leaks yeah
look at that there is a
pretty good puddle of water here
i don't really want to do any repairs in
the rain and tomorrow morning i'm
getting on a plane with nathan
and we're going to new mexico to do some
desert camping and fishing
and then we come back and we go straight
to north carolina for a week so it's
going to be two weeks
until i'm back here and that's gonna be
a lot of leaves a lot of rain
well we'll see what happens well it's
been two weeks but i'm back
but it actually looks like it's in
pretty good shape
well it's still holding my weight
well gosh darn it this thing's still in
really good shape despite being rained
on for two weeks
i think we need to do some modifications
you need modifications
hey jacob what do you think is that fun
yeah you lift it up high
and then walk walk it over here
[Music]
i gotta do something to give a nice
healthy pitch to this roof
and i got to fill up these gaps in the
wall so wind and water
can't get into the tent
okay there's been a little accident i
took a little bit of a misstep
and stepped on the leg of my 300 carbon
fiber tripod
oh
all right there we go good as new
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
well guys i think we're done with all
the improvements no more wind and rain
coming in through the sides now and
already i can tell it's a lot
warmer i'm starting to break out a
little bit of a sweat all right i think
we're ready to camp in this thing
i'm just going to clean up the campsite
and get my gear
well guys i was planning on camping in
here but we had a bit of a setback
a big rainstorm came in and it caused
the roof to get
so heavy that we had a lot of structural
failure
this whole corner busted loose from the
tree it tore a hole
where the stick is supporting the peak
we've got a partial failure here as well
and it put a lot of stress on the roof
which also caused
some tears here worst of all it is
full of water
all right let that drain so you got some
water in the sides too
oh i just didn't do a good enough job
constructing the roof obviously the
floor has no problem
holding water so the duct tape can do it
but i
wasn't as careful building the roof as i
was the floor because i was worried
about the floor dumping me on my butt in
the middle of the night
this is really kind of sending me back
to the drawing board i gotta
think about what to do about this but it
needs to dry out before i can do
anything
well guys i've been mowing this over for
a week now and i think there's no
helping it if i want this thing to be
watertight i've got to cut
the top and sides off and redo the roof
and walls from scratch
but i'm already five weeks and 96 rolls
of duct tape deep into this project
and this video is already 20 minutes
long so i don't know if i can do that
in this video but i think this project
could benefit from a fresh pair of eyes
so i'd like to challenge
zachary fowler with the youtube channel
fowler's makery and mischief
i want to challenge zach to see if he
can build
an awesome duct tape shelter but if you
guys want to see me try again to build
something bigger
better and watertight make sure to click
like subscribe and share this video
and i'll make sure to give this another
crack but thanks for watching guys and
don't forget to click subscribe to the
outdoor boys youtube channel we put out
new videos
every saturday morning see you then if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
let me get you down all right
hold very